gehen jetzt nach linz in österreich dort
trifft sebastian kurz der kanzler den
ministerpräsidenten von bayern markus
fördern und oberösterreich das ist eine
sehr gute eine sehr langjährige eine
sehr traditionelle freundschaftliche
verbindung im kulturellen bereich im
auch zwischenmenschlich
organisatorischen bereich wenn ich nur
erinnere an die leider gegebene
katastrophe 2016 in simbach und wie
freundschaftlich dank wer über die
grenze zusammen gearbeitet wurde das
zeigt einfach dass wir hier eine
gemeinschaft haben zwischen bayern und
oberösterreich bei allen bewusst sein
der größten unterschiede gibt es
natürlich auch viele gemeinsame
interessen es ist ein sehr starker
wirtschaftsraum der insbesondere auch an
der oberösterreichischen grenze hinzu
bayern entstanden ist das innviertel ist
einer unserer pulsierenden wachsenden
industrie und wirtschaftsräume und daher
ist auch das thema arbeitskräfte die
hüben wie drüben tätig sind eines das
uns eint und auch der unkomplizierte
kontakt hier
und selbstverständlich das möchte ich
bei diesem anlass auch sagen ist das
thema was passiert an unseren grenzen
und wie gehen wir mit asylwerbern um
eine gemeinsame interessenslage und mir
ist es sehr wichtig und bin auch dafür
dankbar
sollte deutschland hier aus meiner sicht
verständlicherweise einmal schritte
weiterführende schritte setzen dass wir
in enger abstimmung auch unterstützt mit
der von der österreichischen
bundesregierung hier vorgehen weil wir
in oberösterreich keine zustände haben
möchten wir sie 2015 erleben mussten das
1 1 aber in der vorgangsweise ich sage
nochmal sehr dass ihr bei uns zu gast
zeit hoffe fühlt sich hier wohl und
setze natürlich auch weiterhin viele
gute kooperationen zwischen bayern
österreich und oberösterreich des
hauptmann herrn ministerpräsidenten
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
lieber sebastian der bundeskanzler
als obmann wir haben uns sehr
wohlgefühlt hier weil man sich unter
freunden geführt hat nicht nur dass wir
die sprache sprache sprechen mit dem
richtigen akzent jeweils sondern wir
haben auch ein gemeinschaftliches
politisches gedanken gerüstes uns
verbindet
nämlich dass wir einerseits bürgern
agieren wollen darum ist es uns sehr
sehr wichtig wenn man das heute
vereinbart auf moderne modernität zu
setzen
wir werden start-up zusammenbringen in
bayern und in österreich um junge
wirtschaftliche innovationen zu fördern
wir werden einen digitalen dialog führen
und bei den wichtigsten thema
digitalisierung investitionen in die
zukunft vorzubereiten
wir wollen strategische partnerschaften
im hochschulbereich anleihen haben wir
vereinbart weil wir glauben dass im mid
technologie mit jungen unternehmen mit
technologietransfer wie die zukunft gut
bewältigen können
und gerade hier bei uns zwischen bayern
und österreich auch wachstumsimpulse
setzen können nicht nur für die länder
sondern weit darüber hinaus im gesamten
europäischen verbund wir haben drittens
auch klar gemacht dass wir auch themen
haben die nicht ganz einfach sind wenn
es um verkehr geht aber auch da ist klar
dass wir gemeinschaftlich getragene
lösung und für die besten finden und
dass wir uns bemühen werden mit
verständnis für die jeweils seite
diesseits und jenseits der grenze
verkehrsbelastungen auf daraus so zu
gestalten dass sie für die anwohner und
die bevölkerung verträglich sind und
dass wir viel österreich aber auch für
für bayern dort die zu den besten lösung
kommt da hat man dialog vereinbart der
intensiv ausgestaltet werden muss und
was natürlich ganz wichtig ist für uns
wir haben das gemeinschaftlich getragen
interesse dass wir in europa eine
veränderung und wände in der
zuwanderungspolitik brauchen die
situation wie 2015 darf sich in keinster
weise wiederholen wenn man das aber
nicht will dann muss man geschlossen und
entschlossen auch etwas ändern
darum unterstützen wir die bemühungen
österreicher rückt jetzt ganz besonders
in den fokus im nächsten halben jahr
ich glaube dass der österreich eine
schlüsselrolle mit in europa zu
kontrollierender stützen ist nicht nur
als freund ist aber inhaltlich überzeugt
sind tatsächlich den schutz europas zu
verstärken
die außengrenzen schutz deutlich
auszubauen ich halte die idee von
schutzzonen in afrika für den einen der
schlüssel aufgaben die wir haben können
und wenn wir in europa viel geld für
alles mögliche zur verfügung stellen da
wäre es wirklich sinnvoll mit den
nordafrikanischen staaten tatsächlich
dort bilaterale verträge zu machen
das würde übrigens manchmal mehr helfen
als die diskussion die wir bei uns in
europa selber für
aber das ist eine ganz entscheidende
frage weil wir auch die entschlossenheit
zeigen wollen unsere bevölkerung
gegenüber dass sich das 2015 nicht mehr
wiederholen soll
und wiederholen darf insofern da gibt es
eine große gemeinsamkeit da bedanke ich
mich auch für die möglichkeit uns da
zusammen zu entwickeln auch in der
zukunft
das ist ja ein über die wir haben
einerseits die staatlichen interessen
gemeinsam
wir haben politische überzeugungen
gemeinsam wir haben ist dafür aber zum
schluss sagen auch ein sehr
freundschaftliches verhältnis im umgang
auch das schätze ich außerordentlich
gerade durch den bundeskanzler aber auch
durch alle partner die wir in österreich
haben wir sind die mitte europas ganz
genau die mitte und wir nehmen den
auftrag auch war ein stück weiter eine
kulturelle botschaft zu senden dass wir
eine gute zusammenarbeit wollen deswegen
zum beispiel auch eine gemeinsame
überzeugung wir möchten gerne
österreichische modell übernehmen was
kindergeldzahlungen betrifft innerhalb
des europäischen verbundes dass es sich
nicht lohnen darf die kinder in europa
anderswo leben zu lassen
die kindergeldzahlung auf einem anderen
niveau im eigenen land zu bekommen auch
da muss es eine vernünftige klare
regelung geben
das haben eine gemeinschaftliche
erklärung drin also nochmal danke schön
viel erfolg für die präsidentschaft wir
werden es aus bayern in bayern auch in
deutschland gut begleiten danke herrn
ministerpräsident bundeskanzler kann
ministerpräsident herr landeshauptmann
herr verteidigungsminister sehr geehrte
damen und herren der legendäre
österreichische bundeskanzler bruno
kreisky hat mal gesagt wenn der urlaub
macht dann fährt am liebsten nach bayern
da ist ja nicht mehr daheim aber auch
noch nicht in deutschland nur damit
keine missverständnisse aufkommen wir
sehen das nicht so wir haben einen
anderen blick auf bayern bayern ist
selbstverständlich teil deutschland sie
ist aber gleichzeitig ein sehr starker
wirtschaftsraum ein sehr wichtiger
nachbar für uns und in vielen bereichen
ein nachbar mit dem wir sehr intensiv
zusammenarbeiten und sich die funktion
als bundeskanzler übernehmen durfte und
insbesondere auch im gespräch mit thomas
stelzer darüber nachgedacht habe wie wir
gemeinsam auf den starken
wirtschafts und industriestandort
österreich und insbesondere auch
oberösterreich stärken können da war
eines der themen auf dass wir schnell
gekommen sind die zusammenarbeit mit
deutschland aber insbesondere auf die
zusammenarbeit mit bayern noch stärker
zu intensivieren
wir haben daher gemeinsam danach den
anlauf gestartet sind auf dich
zugekommen und haben im rahmen der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz bei einem
gemeinsamen gespräch dann auch
vereinbart dass es doch sinn machen
würde man eine gemeinsame sitzung der
bayerischen landesregierung und der
österreichischen bundesregierung
abzuhalten
ich bin dankbar dass das heute möglich
war und über thomas stellen zu vielen
dank für die einladung nach
oberösterreich und dass wir auch in
diesem wirklich schönen rahmen in diesem
wirtschaftlich und industriellen starken
bundesland sein dürfen
wir haben heute über mehrere bereiche
der zusammenarbeit gesprochen
wirklich positiv bereich unserer
zusammenarbeit ist neben der kulturellen
und menschlichen kooperation vor allem
natürlich die wirtschaftliche
ministerpräsident hat das schon
ausgeführt bayern ist unser wichtigster
handelspartner unter unseren nachbarn
wir haben ein handelsvolumen von über 30
milliarden
nur damit sich das einordnen lässt
bayern würde man bayern als land einzeln
rechnen
der austausch mit bayern wäre am
zweitstärksten nach unserem austausch
mit den usa das ist also ein wirklich
beeindruckender wirtschaftliche
austausch stehen es hier zwischen bayern
und österreich gibt meiner meinung nach
im interesse beider seiten erst durch
die europäische union was möglich dass
dieser wirtschafts haben so stark
zusammengewachsen ist und wir wollen das
natürlich stärken der ministerpräsident
hat schon ausgeführt wir haben hier
heute vereinbart eine noch stärkere
zusammenarbeit im wirtschaftlichen
bereich im bereich der digitalisierung
auch was universitäten und
innovationsstandortes betrifft wollen
wir die grenzüberschreitende
zusammenarbeit weiter ausbauen
darüber hinaus gibt es die möglichkeit
voneinander zu lernen gute ideen
abzuschauen auch das wollen wir in der
zukunft noch stärker forcieren unter
nachbarn
das ist auch ganz klar gibt es natürlich
auch schwierig
themen auch denen haben wir uns heute
gewidmet flughafen salzburg die transit
problematik in tirol das sind themen wo
wir nicht immer einer meinung sind aber
wo wir natürlich uns gemeinsam
anstrengen müssen um lösungen zu finden
und darüber hinaus ein thema das uns
alle sehr stark beschäftigt die noch
immer ungeklärte migrationsfrage
innerhalb der europäischen union wir
übernehmen wir die ersten juli den
ratsvorsitz und suchen hier natürlich
auch nach verbündeten nach unterstützern
nach all jenen die dabei einen beitrag
leisten wollen den außen grenzschutz
endlich zustande zu bringen
sicherzustellen dass wir entscheiden wer
zu wandert und nicht die schlepper
entscheiden dass wir sicherstellen dass
unsere außengrenzen so geschützt werden
dass ein europa ohne grenzen nach innen
auch wirklich möglich wird die realität
zeigt uns dass gerade wir hier im
grenzgebiet zwischen deutschland und
österreich ganz gleich ob in
oberösterreich oder in salzburg das sind
die hauptleidtragenden regionen wenn es
wieder grenzkontrollen gibt und insofern
unser großes ziel hier endlich eine
gemeinsame europäische lösung zustande
zu bringen ich hoffe sehr dass es
unseren deutschen nachbarn gelingt auch
eine gemeinsame linie der
bundesregierung festzulegen
das ist in unser aller interesse dass es
im größten land der europäischen union
am stärksten land der europäischen union
auch eine gemeinsame linie gibt
hoffentlich auch eine gemeinsame linie
in die richtige richtung für einen außen
grenzschutz für den kampf gegen illegale
migration bin aber guter dinge nach dem
sich auch die deutsche position in den
letzten zwei jahren sehr stark verändert
hat dass wir hoffentlich schon in den
nächsten wochen fortschritte erzielen
können
spätestens muss es fortschritt geben am
zwanzigster september wenn es den
informellen gipfel der staats und
regierungschefs unter österreichischem
vorsitz in salzburg geben wird vielen
dank danke herr bundeskanzler
herr bundesminister der bundeskanzler
ministerpräsident der landeshauptmann
nicht darf sie auch noch darüber
informieren dass wir neben den sehr
guten gesprächen heute mit dem
bayerischen freunden auch eine
ministerrat gehabt haben wo aus meiner
sicht zwei ganz wesentliche beschlüsse
auch für das bundesheer getroffen worden
sind nehmen
zum einen die fortsetzung des
assistenzeinsatzes der botschafts
bewachung in wien unter bewachung von
sensiblen objekten die jetzt auch der
auch bis 31.12 jetzt weiter verlängert
wurde
unter dem titel ratspräsidentschaft ich
glaube eine sinnvolle und notwendige
maßnahme die hier auch gemeinsam mit der
exekutive zu bestreiten ist aber zum
anderen meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren freut es mich auch berichten zu
dürfen dass wir im bereich der heeres
struktur neue wege gehen nämlich wenn es
darum geht schmale kommando und
verwaltungsstrukturen zu haben und eine
stärkung der truppe herbeizuführen
und das freut mich ganz besonders dass
der landeshauptmann heute auch hier ist
mit dabei und ich ihm auch und ein
anderer landeshauptmänner natürlich auch
mit auf die reise geben kann dass er
selbstverständlich starke
militärkommanden geben wird und
selbstverständlich auch und darauf liegt
auch der focus starke pionier und
sicherungs truppen die im bedarfsfall
bei katastrophen etc
auch rasch verfügbar für die länder auch
sind meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren assistenzeinsatz als stichwort
möchte hier vielleicht auch nur einen
kurzen ausblick geben wie bringt sich
das österreichische bundesheer in die
ratspräsidentschaft ein
ich glaube ja hier haben wir einen sehr
engen anknüpfungspunkt auch wenn es
darum geht den gemeinsamen wunsch nach
sicheren außengrenzen sicherzustellen
mit dem assistenz modell das in
österreich seit jahrzehnten gelebt wird
sehr erfolgreich auch gelebt wird und
wir wollen auch dieses modell auf der
europäischen ebene vorstellen und
vertiefen und sind davon überzeugt dass
auch das ein weg ein wirklich wichtiger
beitrag sein kann diesen wichtigen eu
aus und grenzschutz entsprechend
sicherzustellen
herzlichen dank danke herr
bundesminister wir dürfen zu allen
fragen kommen das heißt vielleicht ein
repräsentant der deutschen gäste ein
deutsches medium bitte sehr
herr bundeskanzler ich habe eine frage
zum schutz der aussengrenzen wenn sie
sagen wir hat leidtragenden regionen in
salzburg und oberösterreich wenn die
österreichischen grenzen im süden
sicherer werden das problem doch auch
nicht oder
schauen sie ich glaube die zwei
varianten die es gibt ist entweder wir
kehren zu den binnengrenzen zurück oder
wir haben sichere außengrenzen in der
europäischen union ich habe 2015 schon
davor gewarnt dass wenn eine politik der
offenen grenzen dafür den außengrenzen
betrieben wird
wenn flüchtlinge migranten illegale
migranten quer durch weiter gefunden
werden bis nach mitteleuropa wenn wir
zulassen dass nicht dublin konform man
sich aussucht in welchem europäischen
land man einen asylantrag stellen möchte
wenn man das alles zulässt dann führt
das dazu dass das europa ohne grenzen
nach innen in gefahr ist und als
überzeugter europäer und als junger
mensch der eigentlich mit dem europa
ohne grenzen fast schon gefüllt als
selbstverständlichkeit aufgewachsen ist
ist das ein szenario das ich zutiefst
ablehne und dass ich als absolut negativ
werden würde
und insofern auch ein überzeugter
einsatz dafür dass für die
migrationsfrage in den griff bekommen
dafür dass wir unsere außengrenzen
schützen
es kann nicht sein dass nur weil wir als
europa nicht entschlossen genug gegen
schlepper vorgehen nur weil wir als
europa nicht bereit sind unsere
außengrenzen zu schützen
dass das dazu führt dass wir die größte
errungenschaft der europäischen union
nämlich ein europa ohne grenzen nach
innen in frage stellen oder sogar
gefährden und das ist leider gottes
nichts was ich einfach nur so dahin sage
sondern schauen sie sich die situation
an
es gibt wieder grenzkontrollen zwischen
europäischen mitgliedsstaaten und
österreich das hier ja oftmals
hingestellt wird als wären wir hier die
täter in der migrationsfrage
wenn nicht das land das mit
grenzkontrollen begonnen hat sondern
deutschland war das erste land dass
grenzkontrollen in der europäischen
union eingeführt hat aufgrund einer
überforderung in der flüchtlingsfrage im
jahr 2015
danach sind andere nachgezogen und die
grenzkontrollen in europa sind mehr und
mehr geworden und insofern glaube ich
sollten wir durchaus aus den letzten
jahren als europäische union die
bereitschaft haben zu lernen einzuteilen
was ist falsch was funktioniert was
funktioniert nicht und daraus die
richtigen schlüsse zu ziehen und das ist
meiner meinung nach eine stärkere hilfe
vor ort legale wege mittels resettlement
programmen nach europa für oder in dem
ausmaß in dem die jeweiligen staaten
bereit sind menschen aufzunehmen und
darüber hinaus aber ein ordentlicher
außen grenzschutz der sicherstellt dass
das europa ohne grenzen nach innen
weiterhin gewährleistet bleibt
herr voss panik austria playstation sie
eine frage jeweils eine frage für jeden
regierungschef erste frage an sie herr
bundeskanzler
es ist am sonntag im mini gipfel in
brüssel
wir wissen alle wie ernst die lage ist
die deutsche bundeskanzlerin kämpft um
ihr politisches überleben um ihr
politisches vermächtnis sie übernehmen
den ratsvorsitz sie präsentiert sich als
brückenbauer werden sie brücken bauen zu
den skeptischeren staaten wie wir gerade
oder auch salvini und dann sicher so
dass die knappe frage hat merkel ihr
vertrauen ich darf vielleicht anfangen
auch wenn meine meine frage die die
längere war
ich glaube sein wir vorsichtig damit
wenn wir in das echte skeptischen oder
der weniger skeptischen einteilen also
weiß nicht ob ich die diskussion falsch
verfolgt habe aber mein eindruck ist
nicht dass die visegrad staaten
skeptisch waren was den außen
grenzschutz betrifft insofern würde ich
da ein bisschen vorsicht bieten was
diese these betrifft wir positionieren
uns als brückenbauer das ist richtig wir
haben
gute gespräche mit angela merkel letzte
woche geführt wir hatten eine sitzung
als bundesregierung gemeinsam mit der
europäischen kommission wir hatten
gestern die präsidentin des europäischen
parlaments in wien zu einem austausch
mit der bundesregierung
ich werde morgen die visegrad staaten
treffen am sonntag angela merkel und
andere speziell nochmal zur
migrationsfrage am freitag den
ratspräsidenten donald tusk und nächste
woche dann noch immer an allen grund
einige andere regierungschefs um
bestmöglich die übernahme und den
ratsvorsitz vorzubereiten das ist das
was wir gerade tun in diesen wochen und
ja natürlich gilt was ich immer gesagt
habe wir wollen brückenbauer sein
innerhalb der europäischen union hier
zusammenführen um als europäische union
voranzukommen stärker zu werden und vor
allem auch um die migrationsfrage
endlich zu lösen oder zumindest einen
ordentlichen fortschritt zu erzielen das
ist das klare ziel und was ich gut finde
und das ist glaube ich der entscheidende
punkt ist dass wir von der diskussion
und der streiterei in der europäischen
union über die zwangs verteilung mittels
quoten jetzt ein stück weitergekommen
sind hin zur wirklich entscheidenden
frage nämlich zur frage wie schützen wir
die außengrenzen und wie verhindern wir
dass weiter winken bis nach mitteleuropa
das werden auch die hauptthemen des
gipfels am sonntag sein
ich möchte nur festhalten es geht bei
dem gipfel am sonntag nicht um deutsche
innenpolitik sondern es geht um die
lösung der migrationsfrage die längst
überfällig ist
und ja wenn deutsche debatten dazu
beitragen dass es jetzt wieder eine
stärkere dynamik auf europäischer ebene
gibt dann nehme ich das gerne zur
kenntnis ich glaube nur unser ziel
sollte schon sein oder was wir uns
wünschen würden natürlich auch als
ratsvorsitz in zukunft ist dass es eine
geeinte linie in deutschland gibt das
macht es auch wesentlich leichter auf
europäischer ebene voranzukommen
dass es dynamik gibt und dass es die
bereitschaft gibt sich mit dem thema zu
beschäftigen das finde ich gut denn ich
habe in den letzten monaten immer wieder
den eindruck gehabt dass die zahlen
fünfte zwar nach wie vor sehr hoch sind
da und dort auch neue routen entstehen
aber viele ein interesse daran haben
nicht darüber zu reden
in der hoffnung das ist nie wieder so
schlimm wird wie 2015 und alles was
besser ist als 2015 ist irgendwie
erträglich das entspricht fällt leider
nicht ganz der realität für beobachten
die zahlen der ankünfte sehr genau wir
beobachten genau wenn sich neue routen
auftun
und wir haben als bundesregierung die
überzeugung dass wir nicht erst agieren
sollten wenn die katastrophe da ist
sondern vorher alles versuchen sollten
damit die katastrophe gar nicht über uns
hereinbricht
es geht nicht es geht nicht um
personelle fragen es geht um inhaltliche
frei würde etwas kürzer sein als der
bundeskanzler
20.15 darf sich nicht wiederholen
und das gilt aber nicht nur verbal
sondern muss inhaltlich eine konsequenz
daraus folgen nicht nur in der haltung
sondern auch in der handlung und da gibt
es eine menge zu tun national wie
europäisch national zum beispiel geht es
für deutschland da zu machen dass
deutschland als asylant vielleicht seine
anreize verändern muss indem wir
umsteigen komplett auf sachmittel statt
auf geldleistungen um insgesamt auch die
zuwanderung nach deutschland weniger
attraktiv zu machen wie wir sind spüren
diese inhaltliche frage bedeutet aber
auch wie wir die grenzsicherung steigen
könnte das beste wäre immer der schutz
der aussengrenzen das beste wäre es auch
dass wir gar nicht das problem auf dem
kontinent haben sondern tatsächlich dort
angehend um haben wir sehr viel
sympathie für die idee der
schutzbereiche dort wo sie tatsächlich
entstehen
fakt ist aber auch schlepper und
schleuser sind so clever immer über neue
routen zu diskutieren und um den das
geschäft in der tat nicht zu erleichtern
braucht es auch entschlossenheit im
handeln